she truck coming button I I just always
keep it like oh fuck it's not
intentional I just always forget to take
it out and now it's like oh we should
tree trunk supports come on yeah you get
like this episode two old people making
out and using tongue yes
but one's an elephant and once a fake
and that makes it cute and one is Ron
Lynch from home that makes it awesome
we're already going good job yeah sit
down
nicely done Tory went to the bathroom
came out and said go ahead well done
thanks for coming out John and Merritt
oh listen to my BK he goes up easily
then why he's a perverted kitty yeah
perverted but you're fine with watching
a pig and a cat in or a pig and an
elephant make out a tongue totally that
is hot okay
oh okay so let's let's talk about - you
saying distract us with pink bunny which
is actually what tree trunks and the
pigs kid would probably look like this
is what accept their kid would look like
except that no that still doesn't maybe
it's part my buddies from she's part
body I'm sure she's got long ears stuff
so let's talk about dream of love this
is an episode where okay so the dirty
tricks episode she falls in love with
mr. pig who was going to eat them in the
last tree trunks episode and we just
found that was voiced by Rob legs which
I love he's from home movies a he's a
great voice um and he's got just this
great deadpan throughout this whole
thing cuz tree trunks is so weird as got
this big boys
oh sorry yeah can't live without her you
know very basic minds me of uh Ron
Swanson actually from parks and
recreations I just really got into that
show so just like the Calvin house thing
I'm now going to connect everything to
Parks and Recreation so just saying
Kingdom Hearts
lightning returns I did you just
recently get into that D I guess no
my finger part has a new real bull
lightning returns since it just came
home okay as long as you just got into
it and we can pour it out like bastards
so they fall off and they've been
showing too much public display of
affection I mean everywhere be very
gonna damn cheese sandwich in baby
carriages to this and finally Finn and
Jake decided they want to keep them
apart it's too gross but they sing this
song and everybody feels sad they're
like whoa who feels said fan of Jake
that's not everyone okay and everyone
around them everyone listen to the song
with Jake is like you know the crying is
nothing they feel sad they're like
making out again those are the people
who didn't hear the song it's a very
powerful song to be fair I want you to
sing like tree trunks but and they get
back together and Jake makes that with
the pie that's that's pretty much it um
it's you know again I'm always kind of
shocked how much they can kind of doing
this show cuz not only do they say like
well we can't be in a house together
without being married oh that's indecent
and so that's damn it Naruto over here
go here you won't be on the camera you
look here oh oh now you guys say oh
you're gonna say go away I don't need
you walking back I'd be on the carry
damn Kass now he's giving us the guilty
look of shame
you gotta come II a little bastard I
hate your cast I know and that's fine so
okay I'm not gonna get these keys
distracted look so
he is too adorable neva throws voice I
think it's over there about hearing meow
over there that's precious
so okay all right so you got so sorry
for these distractions we all go it
seriously
Maci we I'm sure you haven't done well
to bring the focus back making there
Tonya Harding joke Tonya Harding hit
someone there you go great focus yeah no
but I did what you told me to are you
seriously think it notice he's nothing
frame though yeah he's not implying but
he's like oh he's such a tempter it's
like oh I'm gonna be referee if I'm not
gonna be on camera oh maybe my techno
it's no this is your show you're being
polite
oh yeah please do cuz I clearly cannot
yeah it's painfully painfully obvious
well do your job man
well yeah so they do the nice little
song and they get back together you have
a colonic it's a nice clock said that
yeah said that okay go to them because
you know they were singing about
dreaming at my lamp to be next to each
other it's a nice lamp
yes isn't it tall thin we should put
Naruto oh I already got your focus off
see that so to everybody you are I will
bring it back okay so they're making out
constantly and I was saying the thing
about oh really you're gonna just talk
about why this is no good yes no good
way no tongue tongue no
okay so not only do they make like the
sex before marriage jokes I mean who
doesn't think they're not that bad about
honestly but they have a scene where
their silhouettes are kissing and you
literally see their tongue stick out
it's like what the hell you know it's I
don't know it that's just weird but you
find it cute strangely I mean I find it
cute because it's so weird and sick and
strange but ya know it's Q because there
everyone has either seen this couple or
been this couple the one that shows too
much public display of affection and I
think pretty much everyone that has seen
them has wanted to beat them and Club
them I almost people where it's like I'm
actually okay for a little bit but they
have it goes past like a week or
something I'm like okay you get you got
stopped like what I see that like you
know what I've gotta like finish it at
the end okay good for them let them you
know it'd be happy if it's like the
first week because that's kind of normal
and stuff but it's like a week I passed
that pass a week you know it's like okay
now it's starting to get okay I'm
talking about do you see a person like
constantly like this couple okay we're
doing yeah I agree
past a week yeah sure those past a week
you know it gets a loll and it's like
let's why don't I just go by tree-trunks
his house uh I said bye and to in uh
that wouldn't make sense ya know they
had to go in to money they ain't just
songs baby carriage into a cheese
sandwich
okay they had a cheese sandwich okay
when the last episode how come Jake just
like stretch his way out of the
spiderweb thing that made no sense it
was clearly visible he could move his
belly and go around
I actually remember he was trying but he
got too lazy he got too lazy oh like you
haven't seen Jake get lazy before oh go
get that ok that kind of makes sense but
they're not very bright which would tie
into you not liking them okay but still
I I liked it because I think especially
in
especially for younger people and
grownup and stuff like that and you come
across your first loves and stuff I mean
this is like this happens all the time
it's like the high school couple
especially is always gonna be like all
over each other people gonna be like
dude come on and it's so scooped that
the kind of address it but it's also
like okay you shouldn't be like ashamed
of doing it just do it in moderation do
it when it's not so annoying sometimes
it's okay to be happy for a couple I try
I first tried to be happy for a couple
went there you know whatever tongue
fencing and stuff like that by then when
like I say way this order goes past a
week or a couple weeks I'm like okay now
you can sort of talk it's time to talk
you know I actually use your words not
just your vowels you know so turn to the
camera speak oh say your piece oh sorry
no I mean I guess for me the problem is
is that they weren't like teenagers
they're an old people couple I think
it's even more disturbing but makes it
funnier to oh because they're like they
should be used as kind of stuff but it's
like you get the feeling they're both
really lonely and they don't see many
people I mean mr. pig never left each
other consistently and that that makes
it all the more funny to me oh I've been
doing this for like months and months
plus you'll have to think about it
where's the first time they really start
making out they walk in front of a stage
and they start making out then you have
tree trunks don't forget her dance can't
we do one v-log without you shaking your
butt no where do you think the hits cut
no it's definitely not from starts doing
that dance and then they start pumping
blood it is all be so weird when they
suddenly like just give a character
doesn't normally have a butt like this
really defined yeah it's always so
strange just selling Tara and it's like
there you almost see a form while they
turn around it's just
I guess made my thing is this to say
okay make out all your freakin one but
the moment someone goes that's making me
feel uncomfortable
stop have common courtesy for what's
going on around you well I don't mind
saying anything or no one's paying
attention to you go to the back of the
body don't right in front they try
they're just not very good at it they're
just not very smart high in other
people's houses various property and
they hide in food which I guess makes
sense for a pig but still they're hiding
in the food it's because they're not
very smart though I think that's the
comedy of it um Club them you know you
like to uh know the one thing that like
didn't make sense - I know saying isn't
weird but the one thing I actually do
legite really didn't make sense to me
because it's like everything else it's a
old it is not very brighter than that
very smart whatever when they're singing
their song and tree-trunks takes out the
apple pie with her trunk yeah she
doesn't have a trunk mitt yeah and I
really thought I thought I'd be playing
here chief well that's up sir a trunk
mitt or like she grabs it and as she
sings she's only just got down and drops
it or something I thought that'd be
funny but she just thinks about like oh
what a missed opportunity for a joke but
patron commits a trunk mitt if there's
any world that would have a trunk mint
enough this one and the trunk meant how
many elephants take out apple pies many
my friend at least in my house I haven't
trained them for years and okay not one
has done it yet successfully it's
destroyed my kitchen but we don't
welcome it wait yeah we've trunkman yeah
come inside